everybody can hear it everybody knows
okay got to attack shot clock's running
down better you butter shoot the ball
and let that guy shoot the ball he
better shoot it
so the rebounding's getting a little
cleaned up can the shooting come along
for the ride
if that guy's shooting you feel much
better curry another three just find him
give him the ball
screen for that guys went home
cleveland takes time
a curry flurry may be on the way otto
porterhouse we had steph briefly shot
clock at seven here he is
coming around again another three just
look at the movement the lead is
dissipating a little bit
warriors are starting the defensive
rebound d lee moving without the ball to
lay it up and in and that's the thing
you can't stop playing if you're the
other yes i think the 19 to two second
chance point stat was shared during that
timeout between the third and fourth on
the bench curry without the ball
damien's there again perfect rubio was
top blocking him
you're coming back though you need to
take the lead you need to crest the hill
and steph does just that
he is an all-around
scorer okoro is there you're too close
to me that far away from the rim you
think you're a good defender i got
to be elita three steals with his 14
points curry 31
and eight more made three steps to
post-op hold him oh what a reverse
finish no it was just a seal he's so hot
right now you have to keep riding him
the eliza looking for a seam d lee big
three got one
so damien lee with nine off the bench
the warriors can run it back draymond's
calling for the ball
d lead down the lane damian to lay it up
and in that's the way to not be three
happy he just hit a three so steph is
gonna ride it out he's played the first
eight minutes of the fourth he finished
the third two
and curry inside and he has 35 they keep
top blocking him they keep getting on
the wrong side 325 left steve kerr
riding steph curry to the barn here jta
down the lane
juan toscano anderson's first field goal
i want to get a good shot here
[Applause]
the lead sitting at six
curry making it nine he's a flame
thrower
nine threes for the 38th time in his
career
oh pickpocket jta
the push ahead cherry picking curry he's
got 40.
he is so crafty
and the cavs have had nothing in the
fourth quarter exactly
and then juan toscato anderson from
draymond
and now steph can rest he doesn't care
about that he knows how good of a
shooter he is
montesquino anderson yeah perfect way to
cap it off
what a night for jta